an ovation for ukraine's ambassador at
the reichstag after germany's historic
decision to send weapons to ukraine
reversing a post-second world war
pacifist policy the creek is a
catastrophe
chancellor olaf schultz also adding new
funding for germany's military and a
similarly historic move from the heart
of power in europe too
for the first time ever the european
union will finance the purchase and
delivery of weapons and other equipment
to a country that is under attack
this is a watershed moment
after financial sanctions with canada
and others the eu adding more measures
targeting russia our airspace will be
closed to every russian plane
and that includes the private jets of
oligarchs too russian airline aeroflot
forced to cancel all flights to european
destinations i mean it's just a total
sea change that happened over a 48-hour
period it's remarkable bill browder has
campaigned for a decade for sanctions
against vladimir putin and his closest
allies the oligarchs hold their money
and so we have to go after the top
russian oligarchs other new measures
include eu sanctions against russia's
ally the lukashenko regime in belarus a
wider ban on russia's central bank from
accessing its foreign reserves and
kicking many russian banks out of the
swift international bank payment system
full details on that are still to be
decided but some russian banks will be
exempt likely to allow europe to buy
russian oil and gas so there are
questions to be asked here and ways to
extend the reach of these sanctions in
the days to come analyst josh lipsky
believes the block on foreign reserves
could cause a shortage of cash or even a
run on russian banks plus inflation plus
food prices going up within russia plus
supply chain shortages now so all of
those things together put enormous
pressure on the russian economy
in the vatican prayers for peace rather
than sanctions pope francis calling on
more governments to open up humanitarian
corridors for refugees sanctions against
russia are not just coming from world
governments oil giant bp says it's
selling off its stake in a russian oil
company and fifa the international
soccer body says russia's national teams
cannot play using their flag or anthem
that is if any country agrees to play
against them